I think it's about communication mom
never mentioned it to me that's not
that's not fair I don't I don't think
it's fair how it was handled if how it
was handled is how you're telling me I
don't think that's still I never
mentioned it and Mom feels like she
has
like is entitled almost I can't explain
it like she doesn't have to get my
permission and I'm like no of course no
one has to get my permission but if you
want to have a good relationship and
make me not want to run and if I did it
to Kim she would
freak out but to me it was more personal
I think that's why it like hurts my
feelings it was my actual wedding the
year your sister got married you then
made a deal to do this fashion show
don't do it the same year that comes out
four months later it's not like I did
their campaign and then she did the
campaign right after like who cares
that's business it's my actual wedding
and that wasn't a business deal for me I
did it because it felt really personal